guess what my patience is run out  pansexuality is not inherently biphobic  they are both valid sexualities both of  them and while yes i have seen pansexual  people use that label for questionable  reasons they pretty quickly get it once  you explain things to them they do and  not only that but do you know who likes  to use specific or micro labels  neurodivergent people sometimes we just  have to do whatever we can to feel safe  and comfortable  and using a more specific label can be  our outlet for that if you took all that  energy you spend calling people biphobic  and saying they're performing by erasure  and just educated them there would be  less biphobia there would be less by  erasure because you've explained it and  people will know the difference i have  [ __ ] had it with you guys jesus  okay i've only got a couple minutes here  she's obviously wrong about everything  here